hey youtubers is charlie and in my last
couple of Doctor Who videos I asked you
to submit all your questions about the
master the new character Danny pink and
series 8 in general so I picked 10 of
them to answer in this video with one
cool bonus question mostly you guys have
been asking about the possibility of a
new master as well as the Danny pink
character possibly being the master
that's actually a new rumor that's just
come during this week in addition to
those master rumors there's also been a
lot of talk about what the episodes are
going to be in series 8 so my next video
is actually going to cover that feature
to subscribe to get it if you're finding
me for the first time so a couple quick
things before we get started I'm
actually getting ready to change my
YouTube avatar to something like this
it's just a sure-lite gb just it kind of
looks a little bit more like my face
it's just in keeping with kind of the
general content that I do but you guys
can let me know whether you think it
looks nice or you think it looks
terrible but it won't look exactly like
this but it'll be pretty close whenever
I get the final version I'll let you
guys know who the artist is so you can
check out all our other stuff on our
deviantart page so now time to answer
some questions number one comes from
cure 9269 who says what about Steven
John Shepherd from EastEnders he grew a
beard and said he's working on something
secret you're talking about the new
master so Steven said he was working on
something secret then took a picture of
himself with a classic you know who
master beard on the South Wales
coastline dr who was actually filming
series 8 near that area around the time
that the picture was taken so the mirror
is reporting that he could have been
filming scenes with Doctor Who as the
master it's a long shot because all we
have is evidence is this picture as well
as the comments that the mirrors made so
let's add them to our top 5 list of
potential new masters question number
two incredible Dalek asks willow kapali
screwdriver be the ones that River Song
will give him I don't think so River
Song screwdriver was actually featured
in the last night the one that Matt
Smith gave her the modified one I think
Capaldi will get a new one I'm sure
they'll use the moment to tell some more
regeneration jokes but we have no idea
what it'll look like hopefully they will
reveal an image of it while they're
still filming series 8 or at least
during comic-con this summer question
number 3 kitty kerosene asks that's
actually pretty cool name what if the
Danny pink character is a red herring so
good comment you're talking about Steven
Moffat using the Danny pink character as
a mask for someone more sinister like if
Samuel Anderson is playing another
character pretending to be Danny pink
there was a recent blog posts on Katter
Boris that claims Danny pink maybe the
new master I think it would be an
interesting twist a teacher at a very
famous school in the Doctor Who universe
one that the current companion just
happens to work at turns out to secretly
be the master Derek Jacobi's master did
store his true self inside a pocket
watch so if Danny pink does pull out a
pocket watch then we can all oh
high-five each other question number 4 j
ER x will series 8 have episode pairs
like series 1 through 6 or none like
series 7 so you're generally asking
about episodes having two parts the only
announcement they made so far about the
episodes is that Moffat has said that
the season will air all the episodes in
consecutive weeks there hasn't been an
official announcement about the
Christmas special but I think we should
expect one so it is possible that we
will get another two-part episode but
they haven't announced anything
officially yet question number 5 Amelia
pond asks do you think that Danny maybe
some companions relative or son no I
think given the level of rumors about
him being a secret other character he's
not gonna be biologically related to any
of the other characters on the show if
he is the master or someone just as bad
then I'm sure there will be some sort of
implied shared history with the doctor
in all likelihood he just knows Clara
the way you get to know people at work
though just totally normal question
number 6 kaya Hiller desks the
speculation going around the Capaldi's
only going to be on for series 8 what do
you think so his contract is only for
series 8 so he's only officially doing
one series but that doesn't mean that
he's leaving the show he has been a
lifelong fan of Doctor Who so he does
have a lot of reverence for the role
most of the time actors leave because
they get tired creatively or they have
better opportunities elsewhere like Matt
Smith and Karen Gillan's movie careers
taking off in Hollywood if Capaldi does
only stay for one series it would
prevent some interesting challenges to
the story how would the finale work and
then wouldn't they have to do another
Christmas special regeneration like last
year also casting new doctors can be
difficult they announced Capaldi before
the 50th anniversary and I think that
they had cast him within a couple months
of Matt Smith announcing that he was
leaving so Capaldi does end up leaving
then they're going to have to announce
up pretty soon question number 7 crazy
brownie 101 asks since series 8 is
supposed to be like classic ooh do you
think that they'll combine the
seriousness of that and the funniness of
modern Doctor Who yes absolutely if
you've seen some of the behind the
scenes images from the first episode you
can see the Capaldi's making funny faces
so there will definitely be some awkward
humor at least at first him just getting
used to his new self and Clara getting
used to him the first couple of episodes
are directed by ben wheatley who has
done a lot of classic 70s horror stuff
so I think his episodes will be serious
just given that he's a horror aficionado
the rest of the series remains to be
seen though whenever I do my breakdown
of all the rumors about the episodes in
series 8 i'll try to talk about the
directors and how their previous
episodes might inform the tone of the
new stuff question number 8 min embo
asks do you know if any old companions
excluding River Amy and Rory are coming
back outside of the ones you mentioned
and they're actually just rumor really
just River I would say no it's possible
since both Clara and the new character
Danny pink port get coal Hill School
that there will be a few classic
companion cameos but if they do appear
then it might be as different characters
than they originally played on the show
question number 9 BB plays games asks do
you think that in series 8 Capaldi's
doctor will meet any of his previous
selves trying to find Gallifrey no but a
lot of people are taking the quote that
Tom Baker made during the 50th
anniversary to imply that I think that
is comment about revisiting old faces
just means that there will be more
classic doctors in the next anniversary
special which will probably happen in
five years I don't think they'd wait a
full 10 years before doing another
anniversary special five years is a long
time in the world of TV question number
10 this is actually a long one but a
really good one lots of fun auto asks
when River Song first told dr. 10 his
name to prove she was trustworthy she
apologized and looked terribly sad when
she whispered it to him he looked
horrified and said there's only one
reason i would tell you my name from the
look on his face the reason is a very
horrifying reason have there been any
theories as to what this reason will be
my first thought when I saw that is that
the doctor is telling her his name
during his death or on his deathbed
during his final death that is since
that's such an abstract concept like the
value I don't
that doctor who the series itself will
ever show the doctors final death
hopefully the show runs forever but I
think logically they would just end it
in a way that allows the doctor to
continue even if he's not on TV anymore
the story would just continue in both
stories and big finish audio dramas
that's just my interpretation of the
scene though that he's on his deathbed
basically and one last bonus question
this actually comes from someone who is
at the Newcastle convention where
Sylvester McCoy said that he knew who
the new master was it comes from husk JV
and it goes I was actually there at the
Newcastle film and comic con where
Sylvester McCoy told us it was odd that
it went out so quickly though there was
only about 70 of us watching the talk he
says the masquerade was actually going
on at the same time and I saw only one
pull out their phone assuming for
twitter or something and the funny thing
was is that everyone just looked at each
other and then back to Sylvester again
so based on your comment is actually
hard to tell if Sylvester McCoy was just
joking or you know pulling everyone's
like or if he actually does know he is
super funny in real life so I think he
was pulling some legs when he said he
knew who the new master was there's
really no way to know who knows who all
the actors coming and going for meetings
about potential roles are you know even
the smaller roles there were actually
rumors that said that people knew Peter
Capaldi was the new doctor within like a
couple days of Matt Smith announcing
that he was leaving I think it's just
important to keep in mind that things
changed all the time in 2012 Matt
Smith's you know had announced that he
was doing series eight and then after
series seven finished filming he
announced he was leaving so he totally
changed his mind so much left to talk
about but thank you so much for
submitting your questions this is a lot
of fun as always like I said the next
Doctor Who video will just be a
breakdown over everything we know about
the episodes in series 8 be sure to
subscribe to get that video i'll try to
post it this weekend or early next week
right now though you can click here to
learn all about that new Danny pink
character and you can click here to see
my top 10 picks for new Time Lords not
new doctors mind you just new Time Lords
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives
you